[Music]  Paris Hilton is engaged the 36 year old  heiress is ready to Wed a longtime  boyfriend 32 year old actor chris Zylka  my mom loves him she definitely improved  she's so happy she already says he's  part of the family paris instagrammed a  series of pics from Chris's Aspen  proposal the actor down on one knee that  they are kissing after she said yes and  yeah the ring and seriously check out  that sparkler Paris also tweeted how  excited she is adding quote I have never  felt so happy safe and loved he is  perfect for me in every way and showed  me that fairytales really do exist ET  was with paris and chris back in may  where they had this to say soulmate what  is it about each other that means you  both know soulmate  you wake up with a smile and you fall  asleep with a smile being best friends  and finally finding someone that I love  and trust and  know that I want to spend the rest of my  life with the best feeling in the world  so when's the wedding  [Music]